>> KANYE WEST WHO NOW GOES BY
SITTING DOWN WITH TUCKER CARLSO
PORT HEADLINE MAKING INTERVIEW.
THE RAP ICON AND FASHION
DESIGNER SLAB LOOMING MINERALS
IN THE MEDIATOR TRYING TO
SILENCE FREETHINKERS LIKE
HIMSELF.
TO GET MY SO-CALLED FRIENDS
HANDLERS AROUND ME TOLD ME IF I
SAID THAT I LIKED TRUMP THAT MY
CAREER WOULD BE OVER AND THAT M
LIFE WOULD BE OVER A.
WE ARE IN A BATTLE WITH THE
MEDIA.
THAT MAJORITY OF THE MEDIA HAS
GODLESS AGENDA.
THE JOKES ARE NOT WORKING.
IT WAS WILD, AND I DIDN'T KNOW
HOW CLOSE MY OWN WIFE WAS TO TH
CLINTONS.
THERE WAS SOME MANIPULATION.
ME NOT SAYING I LIKED TRUMP WAS
A FORM OF MANIPULATION.
IT JUST PRESENTS LIFE AND
PRO-LIFE, 50 PERCENT OF BLACK
DEATH IN AMERICA IS ABORTION, S
I REALLY DON'T CARE ABOUT PEOPLE
'S RESPONSE.
I PERFORMED FOR AUDIENCE THAT
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT GOD, BUT
HERE IS SOME EXCLUSIVE NEW STUFF
.
>> IT DROVE ME CRAZY TO NOT BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT I LIKED TRUMP.
THINK ABOUT IT, IT'S ME, IMAGIN
ME NOT BEING ABLE TO SAY WHAT I
WANTED BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
SOMETHING YOU'RE THINKING, BUT
YOU'RE TOLD YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO SAY IT, IN PUBLIC.
WELL, I NEVER ACTUALLY TOLD
PEOPLE THAT I LIKED FROM WHEN H
WAS RUNNING BECAUSE I WAS
BULLIED BY HOLLYWOOD.
>> I MEAN, THERE WAS A LOT TO
UNPACK WITH THAT INTERVIEW IF
YOU WATCH TO PRAY JESSE, WHAT
DID YOU THINK?
>> I THOUGHT THAT LANYARD AROUN
HIS NECK WAS AN INTERESTING
FASHION STATEMENT.
AND THE ONE THAT SAID 2023.
THE LEFT IS TENACIOUS WITH THE
WAY THAT THEY KEEP THEIR BASE I
CHECK.
HE HAS TO BE DESTROYED BECAUSE
HE IS A BLACK STAR AND HE IS
MOVING AWAY FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
NATIONALLY, THE DEMOCRATIC CAMP
WIN IF THEY DON'T HAVE 90 TO
PERCENT OF THE BLACK VOTE FOR I
IF YOU WALKED AWAY FROM THE
DEMOCRATS AND UCSD IMPEDE OF
OTHER BLACK VOTERS FOLLOWING HIM
.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S FUTURE IS
TOAST, THEY CAN'T HAVE THAT.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE MONEY
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT BE KANYE WEST
, YOU CAN'T BE ANYBODY AND
EXPECT TO GET SHOWERED WITH CAS
BY WOKE CORPORATE AMERICA WHEN
YOU SAY YOU ARE PRO-LIFE AND
THEIR KILLING BLACK BABIES, THA
IS TOO HOT.
THAT IS TOO HOT.
SO YOU'RE ALREADY SEEING PEOPLE
KIND OF PULL AWAY FROM HIM.
INDEED DOES IS GETTING SQUARELY
HE HAD A CONCERT CANCELED.
THE LEFT SAYS THEY DON'T BELIEV
IN BULLYING, BUT IF YOU ARE A
BLACK CONSERVATIVE, YOU WILL BE
BULLIED TO DEATH.
YOU CAN GET YOU CAN IDENTIFY AS
A TREE, SIX GENDERS, BUT YOU
CANNOT IDENTIFY AS A BLACK
CONSERVATIVE.
>> IT'S AMAZING TO ME THAT IF A
MINORITY HAS ANY CONSERVATIVE
VIEWS, THE LIBERALS THEIR HEADS
EXPLODE, THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT T
DO WITH IT AND THEY COME AFTER
US OVER IN OVER IN OVER AGAIN
BECAUSE WE DON'T FIT INTO THEIR
BOX.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE FAC
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO DO THIS
WITH MINORITIES FOR JUST
SPEAKING THEIR TRUTH, JUDGE?
TO KEEP THE TRUTH IS OBVIOUSLY
YOU WERE THE FIRST FEMALE
GOVERNOR AND 20 OR 30 YEARS AGO
I WAS THE FIRST FEMALE THIS OR
THIS AND THIS, AND WE GET A LOT
OF ATTACKS BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
CAN'T CONTROL YOU.
MEAN WE DON'T FIT INTO THE
NARRATIVE IF YOU ARE A MINORITY
YOU'VE GOT TO BE WITH THEM AND
YOU'VE GOT TO BE YOU KNOW,
SUBDUED IN BE RESENTFUL OF MEN
BEING THE CONSERVATIVES, BUT I
TELL YOU, I WATCH THAT WHOLE
INTERVIEW LAST NIGHT AND I WAS
BLOWN AWAY BY KANYE WEST.
I REALLY WAS AND I SAID TO
MYSELF I SAID YOU KNOW, YOU
FORGOT THIS GUY IS A SELF-MADE
BILLIONAIRE.
BILLIONAIRE WITH A B.
HIS MOTHER I BELIEVE WAS AN
EDUCATOR AND HE IS ONE SMART GUY
.
HE TALKS ABOUT HOW YOU DON'T
JUST BELIEVE WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING TO YOU.
YOU LOOK BEYOND, AND THAT IS SO
OBVIOUS.
WHEN HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
KUSHNER'S FOR EXAMPLE IN JOSH
AND JARED AND WHAT WAS GOING ON
AND HE TALKED ABOUT JERROD IN
THE MIDDLE AND HE SAID IT WAS
GREAT WHAT HE DID IN THE MIDDLE
EAST, BUT HE WAS ALSO DOING
OTHER STUFF IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
HE'S NOBODY'S FULL.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH HIM,
LIKE A LOT OF WHAT HE SAID, I
LIKED THAT WHITE LIVES MATTER.
IT'S NOT JUST FREEDOM OF SPEECH
HE HAS THE MOST FUN TO SAY A.
HE DOESN'T CARE IF HE IS IN LINE
.
>> THE THING IS HE'S A VERY
TALENTED MUSICIAN.
HE IS A GREAT BUSINESS PERSON,
BUT COMPANIES ARE NOW LOOKING A
REEVALUATING HIS ENDORSEMENTS.
WHAT IS HE SUPPOSED TO DO IF
THEY TRY TO CANCEL HIM?
HOW DO YOU TAKE ON?
WE ALREADY WORRY ABOUT HOW TO
TAKE ON THE MEDIA, HOW DOES HE
TAKE ON THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
IN THE OTHER SIDE OF IT IS THEY
LOVE TO SAY THAT MINORITIES THA
ARE NOT LIBERAL, THAT THEY ARE
CRAZY.
WE'RE CRAZY BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DEMOCRATS.
HOW IS HE GOING TO DEAL WITH TH
CANCELED CULTURE ON THIS?
>> I THINK YOU WILL FEEL THE
SAME INDEPENDENCE THAT HE FORMS
HIS OPINIONS.
HE WILL CONTINUE TO BE IN A
RETICLE THAT HOPEFULLY FINDS NE
AVENUES OF COMMERCE OUTSIDE OF
CORPORATE AMERICA INC. GLOBAL
CORPORATIONS BECAUSE AS JESSE
POINTED OUT YOUR TOOTH LOOKING
AT COMPANIES LIKE ADIDAS WANTIN
TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES.
JUDGE, I DO NOT KNOW WHAT TO
MAKE ENTIRELY OF THAT INTERVIEW.
ALL I KNOW IS WHAT I WAS
WATCHING WAS INTERESTING.
THIS WAS AN UNVARNISHED
AUTHENTIC HUMAN BEING GIVING YO
THEIR OPINION IN ALL
SELF-AWARENESS.
HE STEPS BACK AT MOMENTS IN THA
INTERVIEW AND SAY I DON'T KNOW
HOW I'M COMING ACROSS RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS SUCH A AUTHENTICITY TO
THAT, BUT IT MAKES ME WANT TO
HEAR MORE.
MY MAIN TAKE AWAY IS THE SAME,
THAT IS THE BIGGEST REFLECTION
AND THIS IS THE WAY THAT PEOPLE
REACT TO KANYE.
THERE IS AN UGLINESS IN THE
REACTION THAT REVEALS THE
UGLINESS OF THAT.
I'M GOING TO USE INFLAMMATORY
LANGUAGE BUT THERE ARE OVERSEER
ON THIS PLANTATION THEY DO NOT
WANT AN INDEPENDENT BLACK MAN T
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT THOUGHT AND
THEY ARE WILLING TO DESTROY HIS
REPUTATION FOR EXHIBITING THAT
INDEPENDENT SPIRIT IT IS ABOUT
THE LEAST THING I CAN IMAGINE T
DENY A HUMAN BEING THEIR
INDIVIDUALITY.
TO FORM THEIR OWN OPINIONS, IT
IS BEYOND UGLY.
>> YOU'VE BEEN AROUND THE BLOCK
ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT KANYE WEST
IS A PROVOCATEUR, HE IS DOING
THIS TO GET A REACTION.
I REMEMBER CLEARLY CHRISTINA IN
2005 HE SAID GEORGE BUSH DOESN'
CARE ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE.
THAT WAS KANYE WEST ALSO, BUT H
WAS ON EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE SIDE
.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, ARE YOU
SAYING HE IS AN AUTHENTIC?
>> I'M SAYING WHEN YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO IS AN ARTIST IN A
PERFORMER IN AN ENTREPRENEUR,
HOW MUCH OF WHAT THEY ARE SAYIN
DO THEY REALLY BELIEVE AND HOW
MUCH DO THEY SAY FOR IMPACT AND
AFFECT.
WE KNEW WITH TUCKER FIRST OF ALL
, WHY DIDN'T HE CHOOSE TUCKER
TO DO THIS INTERVIEW.
HE KNEW THAT UP ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT MAKE LIBERALS CRAZIEST,
TUCKER CARLSON WOULD BE THE GUY.
THERE HE SITS WITH TUCKER
CARLSON AND HE HAS THE PENDANT
THAT JESSE REFERENCED DOESN'T I
HAVE LIKE A FETUS IN IT?
>> AND ULTRASOUND.
TICKET NOW, DO PEOPLE DO THAT,
TO PEOPLE WHERE A NECKLACE IS
BREATHTAKING IT WAS AN
ULTRASOUND.
>> EVEN IF YOU TAKE ALL OF THAT
ASIDE, I THINK EVERYBODY WANTS
TO SAY THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
WITH HIM, AND HE HAD A LOT TO
SAY.
WHAT I TOOK AWAY FROM IT WAS
HERE IS A MINORITY MALE THAT IS
EXPRESSING CONSERVATIVE VIEWS.
WHAT I DON'T WANT IS HIM BEING
HIGHLIGHTED IS AN EXCEPTION TO
THE RULE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF MINORITIES
OUT THERE.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, HISPANICS,
INDIANS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF MINORITIES
OUT THERE WHO THINK LIKE HE DOE
AND REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE TO
EXPAND THAT TECH.
THERE IS A LOT OF CONNIE'S OUT
THERE, I HOPE WE GO AND REALLY
START TO RE-CREATE THE REST OF
THEM BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
ESPECIALLY AFRICAN-AMERICANS WH
SAW DURING COVID THAT HERE
YOU'VE GOT LIBERALS WHO THINK
THEY CAN'T PICK THE SCHOOL FOR
THEIR CHILDREN OR THEY THINK
THAT THEY CAN'T GO TO THE DMV
AND PICK AN ID SO THEY CAN GO
VOTE.
MINORITIES HAVE BEEN TREATED
POORLY BY THE DEMOCRATS FOR A
LONG TIME.
THIS IS REPUBLICANS TIME TO GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH THEM ON WH